[Applaudissements]
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des armées
à la veille des cérémonies mémorielle du
11 novembre les représentants du monde
combattant sont en émoi en effet le
devenir de l'office national des anciens
combattants et victimes de guerre est
plus qu'incertain alors même que le
champ d'intervention de l'onacvg s'est
considérablement étendue avec notamment
la prise en compte des victimes du
terrorisme
le projet de budget 2020 se traduit par
de lourds transferts de charges
reportées sur sa trésorerie
en l'état actuel de la réorganisation de
l'onacvg la débudgétisation ainsi opérer
n'est pas soutenable au moment où la
restauration de l'unité nationale
devrait être une urgence au moment où le
souvenir de nos glorieuses aînées
devrait être un exemple vous laissez à
bercy le soin d'étouffer leur mémoire
que comptez-vous faire madame la
ministre pour enrayer cette dangereuse
inclination pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame la secrétaire
d'état auprès du premier ministre porte
parole du gouvernement madame merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je voudrais d'abord
d'excusés madame florence parly ministre
des armées qui préside actuellement
l'hommage national en la mémoire du
brigadier-chef pointeau à valence comme
vous évidemment le gouvernement est
extrêmement attaché à l'office national
des anciens combattants et des victimes
de guerre qui constitue vous le savez un
interlocuteur de proximité et de
solidarité pour le monde combattant
ainsi que notre opérateur principal en
matière d'action mémorielle sur les
territoires vous avez évoqué les mesures
inscrites dans le plf 2020 et les
craintes qu'elles peuvent susciter je
veux aujourd'hui vous rassurer
pleinement et entièrement parce que
d'abord les mesures d'économies prévues
qui se monte à 2 millions d'euros et qui
comporte effectivement des réductions
d'effectifs sont liées à la mise en
place d'une dématérialisation à la
baisse du nombre de bénéficiaires et à
la réorganisation des fonctions de
l'administration centrale
cette évolution je vous le rappelle a
été votée par le conseil
d'administration de l'onac
vg en présence des organisations
syndicales et il n'y a pas eu
d'opposition parce qu'elle n'impacte pas
le réseau départemental de l'office qui
lui sera maintenu dans son intégralité
les fonctions d'accueil étant évidemment
préserver nous avons effectué par
ailleurs un prélèvement de 17,5 millions
d'euros sur la trésorerie de l'onac est
un prélèvement exceptionnel qui se
justifie parce que la trésorerie de
l'onac avait été excédentaire dans des
proportions anormales quand on compare
avec d'autres opérateurs publics
ça n'est pas évidemment un prélèvement
qui portera atteinte à la réalisation
des missions de l'onac nous nous
emportons évidemment garant vous l'aurez
donc compris le gouvernement est
particulièrement attentif à la
préservation de l'onac dont les missions
sont indispensables tant dans
l'accompagnement des anciens combattants
que des victimes d'attentats dans notre
pays que de préservation de la mémoire
combattante je vous remercie
tu connais je convoque la mémoire et
vous invoquez la comptabilité
sauf votre respect cette responsable
répond ce n'est pas au niveau
à l'heure où le brigadier ronan pointeau
vient de trouver la mort en opération au
mali à l'âge de 24 ans samedi dernier
les coups de rabot budgétaire portées à
l'office national des anciens
combattants et victimes de guerre sont
insupportables alors je laisse bien
volontiers au plus célèbre de nos
collègues sénateurs le soin de vous
apporter la réplique ceux qui paient
heureusement sont morts pour la patrie
ont droit qu à leurs cercueils la foule
vienne est pris entre les plus beaux
noms leur nom est le plus beau toute
gloire près 2 passes et tombe éphémère
et comme ferait une mère la voix d'un
peuple entier les bears en leur tombeau
entendez madame la ministre la voix de
victor hugo et donner réellement à
l'office national des anciens
combattants et victimes de guerre les
moyens d'accomplir son devoir et sa
noble mission